médaillés pour avoir sauvé la vie de son
professeur anaïs dos santos élève en
terminale au lycée jean vilar à plaisir
a reçu vendredi 30 avril jour de son
anniversaire
la médaille de la ville pour son geste
héroïque la semaine dernière sept jeunes
filles à pratiquer la manoeuvre de
heimlich sur son professeur qui est en
train de s'étouffer avec un petit gâteau
pendant une pause interclasses d'un
moment j'ai senti une pression sur
l'estomac et en fait c'était risqué à
moi qui m'a compris mais l'estomac et du
coup algérie curgies telle ou d'une
catho par terre et pop j'ai retrouvé ma
respiration servent très rare geste tout
simple que elle m'a sauvé la vie que
c'est ça qui en 3 mais elle a eu la
présence d'esprit de sang-froid et la
prend et screen intervenir c'est
vraiment c'est extraordinaire ce gestes
de premiers secours anaïs dos santos l'a
appris au collège en soit le pétiole là
ça se résume pas non plus qui est à la
manoeuvre de heimlich quoi c'est ça nous
apprend aussi à avoir faim à prendre les
appeler les pompiers enfin leur donner
les bonnes en faute ça donc c'est pas là
que d'une seule vnf pas c'est plein
d'autres choses vont rester
c'est bien de le savoir en fait présente
lors de la cérémonie la mère de plaisir
à saluer le courage de la jeune fille
quand il ya des jeunes
je veux dire qu'ils qui seraient pas
venus même d'ailleurs nous le dire parce
que moi j'avoue que je n'ai appris
presque plus par la presse lorsqu'il ya
une modestie derrière eh bien il faut
valoriser sa et montrer qu'on a une très
belle jeunesse il faut où il faut
vraiment le faire
oui c'est important le professeur benoît
meurice encore ému et choqué de cet
événement cherche désormais à passer de
certificats de prévention et secours
civiques à l'image d'anaïs